it was an unusual venue for the hastily
organized high-level meeting before the
situation in serious Italy province
could be discussed turkish President
Recep Tayyip erawan was treated to a
show of Russia's latest air capabilities
and that Russian ice cream then they
discussed the issue the Turkish
president really traveled to Moscow for
the escalating violence in Italy
calling it the humanitarian tragedy
everyone came to ask Claire Amir Putin
to rein in Syrian forces terrorists
continue to shell Russian positions and
Syrian forces they try to attack Russian
bases we hope that the de-escalation
zone will be a refuge for the rebels and
should not be a platform to make attacks
we discussed joint measures to
neutralize terrorists hotbeds in Eid Lib
and to normalize the situation in this
region and in Syria as a whole angered
by an attack on a Turkish convoy in
northern Syria earlier this month and
the surrounding of one of turkeys
observation posts the behavior of Syrian
forces is unacceptable the provocations
by the regime have reached unacceptable
levels I would like to say it is
especially by our borders our right to
self-defense and this leaves us no
choice
we have to act to protect ourselves
Russian and Turkey have been fighting on
opposite sides of the war in Syria but a
relationship has grown closer in recent
years with increasing economic and
military ties during a dorrance visit to
Putin's Air Show both leaders couldn't
stress enough how close their nations
have become symbolizing this was the
delivery of the Russian s400
anti-missile defense system to Turkey on
Tuesday but despite the warm words the
focus was on their differences in it
lift and if Putin can make sure that
erawan doesn't go home empty-handed
while our one might not have got what he
wanted in it lip his host Putin made
sure their friendship was in good shape
step fasten al-jazeera Moscow